hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
the game where I played - sorry the
video where I play scary games it's not
a game this isn't a game nothing about
this is a game this is real life well I
mean it's a video of real life it's not
actually real life everything that
you're seeing is just a video on a
screen it's not real known as Israel
everything you see on the Internet is
just a reflection of what once was and
not what is you don't know where I
really am you don't know who I really am
just kidding it's a video all right
let's play some scary games
[Laughter]
oh hi oh I think this game is called the
last door
alrighty then I love the 4 by 3 ratio
it's very good Oh
jiggle-jiggle Oh Jude what's keeping you
are you enough soul for told you follow
the coin around and take a last door on
the left
[Music]
last one on the left you got it bud oh
that's a good pooch e last door on the
left
last one on the left well this is the
last door on the left in this particular
hallway oh that's a but it's a but it's
cat but it's also a but I'm seeing a but
let's see it oh you see it a but on that
overlay a but on top of that the two
cheeks you see that that's a but danger
more buts that's a penis okay that's I
don't know what I'm seeing there all
right cool okay uh that's Thomas
Jefferson a
okay oh sure sure sure sure
yeah oh okay
I also solved this it's this place it's
the hallway in this place great I don't
want to see I'm hungry gonna live
thirsty mium I am do all right a whole
lot of nothing
is that a graveyard good probably
indicative of something hot I don't know
about this don't know about that okay
but should I even bother trying any of
the doors are they ever gonna open
what's happening Oh oh that's different
okay I'm guessing that it's gonna be a
looping hallway but something's gonna be
different each time just too subtle
something all right you know what I'm
not even gonna bother to try the doors
hey if there's an easter egg that
requires me to get one of these doors
I'm not gonna annoy everyone with the
jiggle physics of this game oh god that
is just horrifying I'm gonna go in there
head first baby put me in coach I want
to go out the danger zone that was
horrible
I hated that I completely forgot about
the elevator my skin is crawling that
doesn't usually happen with horror games
these days oh and fish is so surprised
somewhat the chairs up by the way if you
could I spy the difference on that one
all right it's pretty cool
not bad you're gonna open up again
what's gonna be different this time
Thomas Jefferson hey buddy
he wanted a company just just gonna
shout I'm gonna go now I'm gonna go I'm
leaving
thank you I don't know the light the
glorious light of which there is no
darkness I'm not going down that hallway
for the life of me I can see monsters
and demons peering at me from the
darkness they're horrible they're
glowing red eyes they're big snarling
teeth they're evil and I will not touch
them go away I hate you that's how you
get rid of a demon you remember that
scene from The Exorcist where it was all
like I get out demon I hate you and then
demon got out of the body
big gone okay good yeah you fish you
said anything about this oh thank you
for your contribution
all right cool good hello oh good it's
just as dark down this hallway is it was
down the other one if anything it might
actually be a little brighter so you
know that's that's kind of good if we're
all being honest this is this is the
ideal situation
ah what my spider senses are telling me
something
getting a spider tingle the tip of my
taint I'm I'm getting a little chafe
that's Indian see the fish where's the
fish is the fish there fish please speak
to me fish I can't see oh god I hope the
fish is there always the fish they're a
little askew I can barely see it's so
dark
all right cool good grilling I'm glad I
am glad we're all glad I'm glad you're
glad he she me we glad stop I hate you
you are legally now bound to not mess
with me I I guess technically if the
whole hallway is mirrored the bright is
now left and that should that that makes
sense now that makes sense I'm gonna go
that makes sense
I tried you cannot criticize me I was
attacked by demons that didn't respect
the hate rule not my fault okay well
that was horrifying
great good stuff good stuff a plus I
like that that was good is horrible
horrible all right so this is siren head
in Russia 3d horror game 2020 I have a
funny feeling that this is an entirely a
horror game but what what right do I
have to suggest that I'd be a horrible
person if I went into this didn't
thinking it was gonna be the most
terrifying experience in my life so here
we go
I have to go to the store I have to this
hot poop Oh Oh God like there's my
keyword Oh Frick what what is what
[Music]
[Laughter]
diamond Jesus Christmas what oh you know
oh it's like I'm in a horrible nightmare
it really is like I'm in some horrible
nightmare I I just I just
is this what Russia's like or it Oh get
out of here
stupid drone drone yeah I can't even
snap that was a dead-on hit okay so I
need to go to the store but you know I'm
not a hundred percent sure where this
store is gonna be oh my oh my god you
know in a weird sense I'm getting a
visceral like deep-seated repulsion to
this in like the base of my soul and I
think that just acid like really
confirmed that this is a horror game
through and through because this is oh
boy oh boy oh boy
hi hey what's up okay that a floating
hotdog great
I'll throw toilet paper at it I missed
all right sure this is the star oh I
need to go home everything's on fire
are these on fire
I'm so scared of those going was that
started oh I got murdered by siren ed
that's a scary siren ed game I've played
yet what guess I'll give that another go
oh wait is that siren ed wait oh my god
that's siren ed up there oh [ __ ] he's
been there the whole time
oh he's gone I killed him I've done it
there's minecrafting all right oh and oh
boy feel bad about that one all right
chief better wait till my stamina
regenerates all right no I can't I can't
I can't [ __ ] foot around I gots to go
baby I gots to go okay here we go in two
and go go baby go I gotta get home I'm
only assuming that siren ed is breathing
down my neck presently that is correct
Rogo a rainy day go away oh Jesus Christ
no not like this no bro bro bro bro bro
bro bro bro bro bro bro bro sif broseph
bro do a more beautiful story was never
told I got home and someone had taken
over already
couldn't believe it quarantines a beast
to us all all right well that's a good
game a triple plus best game ever never
played a better one I have never played
never will play all right this game
contains scenes of explicit violence
and/or
that's why I'm here
it's also called loving flesh it's also
loud it's alway real loud so something
floating behind that press enter to play
that is the whoa whoa whoa milk milk oh
I see I see I see I see oh that's that's
not good
hi babe it was sup baby oh well this is
a problem I just oh okay there's my
diploma it's diploma bow me III buy
violini Winnie I get a you know I guess
I should ha baby how you doing okay
alright
yeah the PD thought the deal of the day
oh here yeah here I win Frick what
hacking
ah ah God it just it bit up 180 so hard
I got vertigo I actually do not like
blood pudding I've tried it I just huh
oh yeah for sure babe hey babe babe
listen hey I'm a flirt by Nature yeah
sure I do
what the hell why is there blood on my
backpack sorry apple juice is that the
name of your rectum why is the absolute
[Laughter]
God you know me sit around anime games
jerking off at Geo games sure I've been
learning Korean you do in your spare
time I raise ducks and I help Lucy and
punishing Souls an internal damnation oh
I also play minecraft you know they use
the use I've never seen you spelled like
that they use
[Music]
yes I will sleep with you oh yeah Dave
yeah sure
yes let's go baby
what your name is so it flows off the
tongue
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I love love and I love life I love the
flesh its supple delights it sets my
heart aflame loving flesh is my favorite
thing our first date and enough fling no
seconds for me one and done they called
me the one bump jump on me [ __ ] I don't
want to replay no I don't want to do it
best game ever good good to last drop
that's what I call good that's what I
call good baby oh this is sleepwalker
nightmares is apparently two parts it's
barely been a lot of updates I don't
know let's see what we got going on here
play part one observer sure I'll do it
hope I fell in a hole
whereas in Demark hey this looks like it
belongs in a museum
hey squeaky I don't know what this has
to do with sleepwalking but a fair hello
apparently I need fine candles
investigate the maze alright the candles
okay so is there something else in this
maze that I should be concerned about
what did I just see crawling across the
ground like that what did I just see
probably fine
whispering the candles it all makes
sense why is there blood coming from
whence this door how much blood is on
the other side of this door am I gonna
get cascaded shining style am I gonna
get murder last okay I could fit through
here I could squeeze I'm supple I'm
flexible
I could make Oh didn't see you buddy
writhing on the ground back there hey
Lexi and zoom oh yeah that's that's
that's a good rise that's a good ride
the baby all right goodbye see you
around I can't close doors or else I
would slam that in your face and never
talk to you ever again however I can
just only ask you to never never come to
my house ever again oh good a running
bar hello oh good
Oh excellent I can't see there's this
class wonderful most wonderful
indubitable man my flashlight is bright
there's a person legs in zoom there's
someone on the ground I'm coming to help
you you are obviously in need of help I
will help you I am coming to help I am
helping hello hi do you need help don't
talk it'll only exacerbate your wounds
apparently all right I see you kid
you're naked why are you naked Lacey and
zoom but also censor censor that but hey
how you doing can I help you you all
right you okay
what's what's the deal with them why are
you naked number one number two why is
this person not Nate
why aren't you naked someone stub their
toe real bad I know the sound of someone
who still I sound the same way too am
all right buddy you keep watching make
sure nothing comes after me
make sure that naked guy stays where he
is I can't open this door all right good
talking to you hey you take care now we
can take a picture on the way out just I
gotta keep moving set all right busy day
what the hell is happening what what
what what what is happening I have no
idea I have no idea I'm so confused I am
so confused I undoubtedly confused oh no
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you okay oh yeah
yeah gonna do the cheap 2012 jump scare
huh sudden jump from down the hallway I
see how you're gonna be look you may get
me with those but that don't mean you
deserve me you know what I'm you know
what I mean no I mean maybe now that I
got the five I don't know that there's
any more maybe that door will be
unlocked no would have been too nice Oh
whose door I haven't opened hello oh the
big-ass key seems to be blue ah
excellent
it's kind of got amnesia vibes to it
just a little bit more penumbra actually
to be perfectly honest Lexi and zoom
dancing room good thank you
all right cool see yourself oh well I
got the key so I can only assume this
goes to that door that was like metal
not the big one but the one that had to
look like a keyhole perfectly fitting in
the natural aesthetics of these caverns
temple or whatever this is you still
writhing I found a buddy you can ride
with just so you know you're not alone
here just so you know you're not alone
you're not alone my friend you're not
alone hello ill you see now that spooky
licks you zoom up more zoom keep zooming
zoom oh look at that ma now that's a
good look right there that bad that's
spooky that's downright spooky a stick
that's spook Alicia's a spooky baby all
right I'm coming for you I'm the monster
aah rawr Oh find me no okay sure
whatever oh okay oh I shouldn't be
looking at that lick see and don't zoom
on that oh hey Lacey and don't zoom it's
uh they're having a private moment I
guess speak am I free am I free to go
away well then what's this door Oh
interesting what are you doing back
there having fun okay
if I use your computer ah Mitch Splosion
Branch gaming anything gaming fattened
or Keshawn of the dread goo phobia
fallen Wolfie okay do not listen to them
whatever they say do not listen they are
not who you think they are
who is no one's talked to me so I
couldn't really not listen to him I
couldn't even listen if I wanted to oh
wow Oh buddy Oh a go beer escape with
security at what
this campus security what does that mean
what other variant are you guys security
are you security I'm assuming you're
security what is it what is that
security are you security hey you mind
if I get that candle I'm real obsessed
with picking up candles apparently hey
good job that's definitely the weapon
you want to choose for operations like
this thank you thank you for your
service thank you thank you all right
all right it's not bad I'm not gonna
[ __ ] on the game however it needs some
work there's a part two I'm good for now
I'm not gonna play the part - the part
one it's not bad I don't want anyone to
like [ __ ] I like his bad cuz obviously
some effort went into it
I like the less is more approach I like
not having an overwhelming soundtrack
that's like there's a time for that and
in this in this case it was that the
ambience was very nice I'd like to so
subtle the little sounds were jumping on
I didn't know where they were coming or
what they were that was great however
why was I collecting candles why candles
why not keys to unlock the doors to go
farther and then it's kind of like a
thing of which the door goes to which
key might get annoying in the well but
if you streamline it could be fun
there's no enemies either and there's no
threat what are the things on the ground
they're not threatening in any way when
I approach something and it doesn't
react at all whether it goes away or it
attacks me those are both better options
than having to just stay there having it
stay there means I go up to it and it
does nothing it makes me not rewarded
for the apprehension I feel if I go
there and in attacks be that rewards the
apprehension if I go there and it just
like even if it just disappears like
poof gone that rewards the apprehension
to be like well that was weird I would
rather it disappear than just do nothing
and stay there and like just the person
writhing on the ground have them die
when I get there have that that tells a
story
they were almost dead if they just stay
riding on the ground then there's no
death it's like I can't help you so you
just seem kind of silly like you're just
an actor they're just like the level
design was good I
chilli I like the level design the the
area was very nice it had a nice
aesthetic to it the kind of like green
lighting and with this weird underground
cavern it was it was boxy yes but you
know you put some effort in putting
rocks and there and making it a little
more varied the weird hallways and the
peeping holes with like something way in
the distance over there that was creepy
and you even did the thing where I go up
towards one of the things at the end of
hallway and then it disappeared that was
infinitely more interesting than going
it up something and that's just writhing
on the ground for no apparent reason
either have it dead or do something when
I come up to it other than that like the
games not bad baby part twos like vastly
improved I had no idea haven't played it
yet maybe I will eventually but I'll
leave this what did that it's not bad
room for improvement alright so that was
three scary games technically four but
two of those were kind of a silly-billy
middle games so you can't forward today
pretty good deal so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you thought down in the comments below
if you want to check out more scary
games they are linked in the description
right down there or suggested videos
there's always those those still exist
they move the comments around on mobile
but this is just videos they're still
there if you see one of my scary games
on there give it a watch go on the
playlist explore way down in there
there's hundreds and thanks again for
watching and as always I will see you
[Music]